police are searching for a northwestern
professor and an Oxford University
employee suspected of murder
both men are considered armed and
dangerous Chicago officers say professor
Wyndham Latham and Andrew Warren a
wanted in connection with the stabbing
death of 25 year old Trenton Cornell
Darrin Lou it happened last week in an
apartment in an upscale Chicago
neighborhood Jericka Duncan is here with
new details on the manhunt during a good
morning good morning Charley authorities
have issued arrest warrants for
first-degree murder for the two men and
are urging both to turn themselves in
and police also say they believe the two
may have fled the state and now the u.s.
marshals are helping with the search law
enforcement officials say they arrived
at this upscale Chicago high-rise to
find Trenton Cornell Duran Lowe stabbed
to death inside a 10th floor apartment
they suspect these two men northwestern
professor Wyndham Lathan an Oxford
University employee Andrew Warren are
connected to the murder
we're shocked just don't go to buy
you know that's this place is very safe
most of the time I've been here 14 years
and I've never heard of any problem
since that police say they have security
camera footage showing Latham and Warren
leaving the high-rise that evening which
is believed to be Latham's residence the
42 year old Latham has been an associate
professor at Northwestern since 2007
teaching microbiology the University
says Latham has been placed on leave and
banned from campus Warren who lives in
England works at Somerville College an
arm of the prestigious Oxford University
System officials say Cornell Duran Lowe
and Latham knew each other but beyond
that connection specifics remain unclear
the Cook County Medical Examiner says
Cornell Duran Lowe died from multiple
sharp force injuries the first-degree
murder warrants say he was stabbed by
both suspects Chicago police tell CBS
News that both Latham and Warren's
passports have been flagged and Warren's
visa has been restricted which won't let
him leave the United States police also
say they were last seen driving a gray
Hyundai sedan Margaret tareka thank you